la russie prépare t'elle une prise de
pouvoir politique en ukraine c'est ce
qu'affirme londres ce samedi selon un
communiqué signé par la ministre des
affaires étrangères britannique la
russie cherche installer un dirigeant
prorusse en ukraine
listre ce donne des noms d'hommes
politiques ukrainiens et poursuit
certains d'entre eux sont en contact
avec des agents des services des
renseignements russes actuellement
impliqué dans la planification d'une
attaque contre l'ukraine si le foreign
office n'explique pas comment ces hommes
politiques pro russes prendrait le
pouvoir à la faveur d'une intervention
armée ou d'un coup d'état la maison
blanche s'est dite extrêmement
préoccupée à la suite des accusations
britanniques
moscou en revanche appelle le royaume
uni a cessé de propager des absurdités
ces accusations interviennent alors que
le ministre de la défense britannique
ben wallace doit pourtant se rendre à
moscou pour rencontrer son homologue
russe sergueï choïgou une telle
rencontre entre les ministres de la
défense des deux pays n'avait pas eu
lieu depuis 2013 en parallèle les
discussions entre les chefs des
diplomaties russe sergueï lavrov et
américaines anthony blinken doivent se
poursuivre dans les prochains jours